>> Jesse: WHAT WAS LEFT OF
CNN'S CREDIBILITY IS COMPLETELY
IN THE TOILET.
THEY SELF-PROCLAIMED FACTS FIRST
NETWORK UNDER FIRE FOR ANOTHER
BOTCHED TRUMP-RUSSIA REPORT.
THEY CLAIM THE PRESIDENT WAS THE
REASON WHY A CIA SPY WAS
EXTRACTED FROM RUSSIA.
THE STORY HAS BEEN DEBUNKED BY
NUMEROUS OUTLETS AND IT TURNS
OUT TRUMP HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
IT AND WASN'T EVEN IN OFFICE
WHEN THE DECISION WAS MADE.
DESPITE ALL OF THAT, CNN STILL
REPORTED THAT THIS MORNING.
NEW NUMBERS SHOW THE NETWORK
SPENT HUNDRED 81 MINUTES HYPING
THE SO-CALLED BOMBSHELL THIS
WEEK.
IT'S NOT JUST CNN THAT'S
CLINGING TO THE BOGUS STORY.
CHECK OUT WHAT NBC ASKED FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE CONDI RICE.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT RUSSIA'S ELECTION
INTERFERENCE ACTUALLY WORKED?
IT ACTUALLY ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
EVIDENCE OF THAT I REALLY DON'T
THINK THAT'S A GOOD CONVERSATION
TO HAVE.
I THINK IT REALLY DOES DEVALUE
THE PEOPLE IN WISCONSIN AND
MICHIGAN AND OTHERS WHO DECIDED
TO VOTE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WHETHER YOU LIKE THIS PRESIDENT
OR NOT.
WHETHER YOU BELIEVE HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN PRESIDENT OR NOT.
LET'S GIVE THE CREDIT TO THE
AMERICANS WENT OUT AND VOTED FOR
SOMEBODY WHO THEY THOUGHT WOULD
BRING CHANGE.
>> Jesse: JUAN, I HAVE A
THEORY.
I THINK YOU MIGHT AGREE.
>> Juan: I AM LOOKING FORWARD
TO IT.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE MEDIA
MIGHT HELP GET DONALD TRUMP
REELECTED AND HERE'S WHY.
ALL THEY DO IS REPORT ON
DONALD TRUMP.
FAKE NEWS, SHARPIE GATE AND THEY
GIVE NO ROOM FOR ANY OF THE
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
YOU DON'T HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT
ANY OF THE OTHER DEMOCRATS.
IT'S TRUMP 24/7 AND I THINK IT'S
TO THE DETRIMENT OF THE
DEMOCRATS RUNNING.
>> Juan: I UNDERSTAND YOUR
POINT.
HE TAKES UP SO MUCH AIR IN THE
ROOM.
>> Jesse: THEY GIVE IT TO HIM.
>> Juan: BOY, DO WE GIVE IT TO
HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK EVERY POLITICAL
CONVERSATION TENDS TO ALWAYS
COME BACK TO DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS STILL THE 100-POUND
GORILLA OR WHATEVER, 800-POUND
GORILLA IN THE ROOM.
>> Dana: 100-POUND GORILLA.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S MY SIZE.
THAT'S NOT A VERY BIG GORILLA.
>> Juan: HE IS THE BIGGEST OF
THE BIG ONES.
ALSO WITH THE CHAOS, LIKE
YESTERDAY WITH JOHN BOLTON
LEAVING AND THE ARGUMENTS FROM
THE PREVIOUS WEEKEND WITH THE
IDEA OF BRINGING THE TALIBAN TO
CAMP DAVID.
IMAGINE, TODAY.
9/11.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN AWFUL.
THE MEDIA HAS TO COVER THE
PRESIDENT.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BUT YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN AND I DO AGREE WITH
YOU.
>> Jesse: THERE YOU GO!
IF WE COULD ONLY DO THAT EVERY
SHOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, TOM?
>> Tom: CNN, I LOVE THE NBC
CLIP AND I LOVE CONDI RICE WITH
THE PUSH BACK.
SHE ALMOST WAS TOO NICE.
SHE SAID THAT'S NOT A
CONVERSATION WE SHOULD HAVE.
HOW ABOUT "STOP SAYING THAT."
STOP SAYING THAT RUSSIA GOT
TRUMP ELECTED.
THEY ARE STILL DOING IT.
SO THEY ARE STILL GOING TO PLAY
IT REGARDLESS, THIS STORY THAT'S
BEEN DEBUNKED AND CNN IS GOING
TO LET IT FADE AWAY BUT THEY'RE
GOING TO KEEP UP THE RUSSIA
THING AND THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP
UP THE "DID THE RUSSIANS GET
TRUMP ELECTED?"
>> Jesse: 181 MINUTES.
THEY PROBABLY BOOSTED THEIR
RATINGS QUITE A BIT.
>> Katie: I DON'T THINK IT
BOOSTED THE RATINGS.
BUT THAT'S A NICE THING FOR YOU
TO SAY ABOUT THEM.
THE INTERESTING THING TO ME IS
THAT CNN AND SAVANNAH GUTHRIE
CLAIM TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
RUSSIA INTERFERENCE IN THE
ELECTION BUT ANYTIME SHE SAYS
AND GIVES RUSSIA CREDIT FOR
MAYBE TILTING THE ELECTION
TOWARDS PRESIDENT TRUMP, SHE'S
ACTUALLY EMBOLDENING RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA AND GIVING RUSSIA A
WIN AND EVERY SINGLE TIME THAT
SOMEONE AT CNN REPORTS A STORY
INCORRECTLY, AND PUTS A CIA
SOURCE AT RISK, AND THE RUSSIANS
THINK --
IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
YOU ARE SETTING UP A SITUATION
WHERE AMERICANS ARE DEBATING
ABOUT THE RUSSIA ISSUE AND
TEARING EACH OTHER APART
POLITICALLY WHICH THE ONE THING
IN THE MUELLER REPORT THAT WE
KNOW IS TRUE, THAT WAS ONE OF
THE GOALS WHEN THE RUSSIANS TO
THE FACEBOOK ADS, TWITTER TROLL
FARMS, TO SOW DISSENT IN
AMERICA.
EVERY TIME THE MEDIA ACTS LIKE
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
INFORMATION AND WORRIED ABOUT
PROTECTING SOURCES, THEY HAVE
EXPOSED THE SOURCE AND THEY HAVE
EMBOLDENED THE RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA BY CONTINUING TO GIVE
RUSSIA CREDIT FOR SOMETHING IT
DIDN'T ACTUALLY DO.
>> Jesse: THAT GOES TO ONE OF
THE THEORIES, DANA, FLOATING
AROUND RIGHT NOW, THE PERSON WHO
WAS AN ASSET IN THE KREMLIN,
PEOPLE THINK HE WAS THE ONE THAT
GAVE ALL THE DISINFORMATION
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP TO
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, WHICH HE
COOKED THE DOSSIER UP WIFE AND
THAT'S WHY HE WAS BROUGHT OUT OF
THAT COUNTRY.
>> Dana: MAYBE THAT'S WHY CNN
IS CLINGING TO THEIR STORY?
>> Jesse: I THINK THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF IT.
>> Dana: EVERYONE IS ON PINS
AND NEEDLES WAITING FOR THAT.
WHEN SECRETARY RICE TALKS ABOUT
IT, SHE UNDERSTANDS RUSSIANS
VERY WELL.
IT'S GIVING RUSSIANS WAY TOO
MUCH CREDIT.
IT'S BUILDING THEM UP TO UP
POINT OF RIDICULOUSNESS.
THE THING SHE DIDN'T SAY, SHE
WAS VERY POLITE, DIDN'T SAY IT.
BUT IF THAT WERE TRUE, WHERE WAS
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION?
THEY HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ELECTION SECURITY IN THE
UNITED STATES AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WILL BE PART OF THE DURHAM
INVESTIGATION BUT I FEEL LIKE
THEY KIND OF GET OFF EASY
BECAUSE NO ONE TALKS ABOUT IT.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD POINT
OUT IS IN THE OLDEN DAYS, LIKE
TEN YEARS AGO, THERE WAS REALLY
NO WAY TO FIGHT BACK WHEN THE
REPORTER WOULDN'T BACK DOWN,
EVEN IF YOU KNEW THE STORY
WASN'T TRUE.
IF THEY WOULDN'T RETRACT IT, YOU
COULD COMPLAIN A LITTLE BIT.
YOU COULD TRY TO GET IT OUT BUT
THERE WAS NO TWITTER.
THERE WAS NO FACEBOOK.
THERE WAS NO DIRECT WAY TO
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY TO PEOPLE
TO SAY THAT STORY IS WRONG.
I THINK IT'S HELPED,
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS BEEN A GOOD
LEVELING OF THE PLAYING FIELD.
>> Jesse: SO YOU LIKE WHEN THE
PRESIDENT TWEETS "FAKE NEWS"?
>> Juan: LET ME REBUT SOME OF
THIS BECAUSE I DON'T AGREE WITH
IT.
CNN, I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
ACTED RECKLESSLY.
THEY ARE STANDING BY THE STORY
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE AND THEY
SAID, "PARTLY RESPONSIBLE,"
ANXIETY OR THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT WITH HAVING MEETINGS
IN THE OVAL OFFICE WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
LATER, A PRESIDENT WHO STOOD BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND SAID I
BELIEVE HIM, NOT AMERICANS.
>> Jesse: EVEN THOUGH
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THE CIA,
SAYING THAT WASN'T THE CASE.
>> Juan: BOTH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND CNN
WENT TO THE ADMINISTRATION
BEFORE THEY RAN THEIR STORY AND
ASKED.
THERE WAS NO DANGER.
THE RUSSIANS KNEW THIS GUY, KNEW
WHERE HE WAS.
NOBODY'S LIFE WAS IN DANGER.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS YOU HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE CNN, WHEN THEY
WERE FOUND TO BE WRONG, I THINK
IT WAS A STORY ABOUT SCARAMUCCI,
THEY FIRED THREE PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: THEY SHOULD FIRE
EVERYBODY BECAUSE THEY WERE
WRONG ABOUT RUSSIA COLLUSION.
>> Juan: THEY WERE NOT.
>> Jesse: JUAN IS CLINGING.
YOU ARE CLINGING.
>> Juan: YOU SAID, YOU'RE
ACTING LIKE RUSSIA DIDN'T
INTERFERE.
WAIT, HOLD IT.
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA DIDN'T
INFLUENCE VOTES?
>> Jesse: TALKING ABOUT
COLLUSION, NOT INTERFERENCE.
>> Juan: WE HAVE A PICTURE OF
OBAMA STARING DOWN AT PUTIN AND
SAYING STOP IT.
>> Jesse: DID IT WORK?
REALLY LISTENED.
>> Juan: TRYING TO GET
MITCH McCONNELL, PUT OUT A
BIPARTISAN STATEMENT.
>> Dana: ALL OF THE BLAME AND
SUP --
>> Katie: IT'S WHAT THE
RUSSIANS WANT, RIGHT HERE.
>> Dana: THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN VERY
SKILLFUL IN TRYING TO CAST ALL
THE RUSSIANS WHEN THEY REALLY
WERE IN CHARGE OF ELECTION
SECURITY.
>> Juan: WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE
HAD THEM DO?
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK
HILLARY CLINTON THINKS OBAMA
SHOULD HAVE DONE SOMETHING MORE?
GUARANTEED.
>> Juan: WHAT WOULD TRUMP AND